the dustin tv wants to get on here and
cut a promo on this uh
silly hair i think that's a great idea
not only do i think it's a great idea jj
i think it's an amazing idea so
let's let let's do that let's let's
let's add let's add our boy dustin to
this because he's
dustin is somebody who has admitted that
his
his mother did drugs while he was in the
womb okay
this is somebody who actually had
problems all right i'm i'm adding him
right now
hey actually sees it yep hey dustin pick
up i'm calling you right now buddy
on skype
hey dustin you there oh it's calling him
it's calling him now it's calling
zombie squad what up dustin
what's going on buddy not so much
hey turn your camera on
there we go now we're talking now we're
talking
all right all right dustin uh
so before we before we do this let's
just i want to get some things straight
just so we know cause she's always
complaining and all this stuff
uh you've told us before that your mom
did drugs when she was pregnant with you
and obviously that affected you right
yeah you right and and you were able to
overcome that and now you're a
successful youtube gaming streamer you
got the zombie squad you got people to
love you
correct yeah all right so let's so so
let's play this here
fish and lazy
as i got older it got worse because my
issues got worse and my family just kept
laughing at me and ignoring it and
mocking me
i was sick and nobody
ever cared
i've had so many issues with my mental
health that my
family completely ignored
dustin you've had issues before right we
all have right dustin yeah i had issues
but i
overcome them that's right and i don't
give a [ __ ] what nobody
says about me it's just words damn look
at listen to that do you hear that
do you hear that adrostia do you [ __ ]
hear that
you just get over it and you go on with
your life
well just go on with your life somewhere
somebody's talking [ __ ] about you
just just go on i mean it's just [ __ ]
words
they're just [ __ ]
words i'm hearing this woman just
complain
complain what she needs is
sam's dick in her [ __ ] mouth to shut
her ass up
[Music]
hot fire [ __ ] dusty covered in with
the heat
i mean so what i mean cutting yourself
that's kind of [ __ ] up but
when people talking about you just just
ignore them
it goes in one ear and goes out the
other here you go
with your life damn or you just stop
complaining about it
yeah cut a promo on them like you do you
just cut you cut sick promos on them
that's just pushed aside
and belittled
and i've been trying to escape them
for so long
[Music]
oh [ __ ] dustin
[Music]
i got a little violin just playing for
her
hey hey put on my weight hey put out my
weight jk
you bleed my ball alone you leave elmo
alone jj
you leave him alone god damn it
god damn it they will follow me for the
rest of my life
and they will push me and they will make
everybody
hate me
no you make everybody hate you lady you
make everybody hate you
she needs to pack up and move from
another
state and and start all over
and maybe people won't hate her but she
keeps on that whining
[ __ ] people can start hating her ass
yeah no
listen man i agree with you go off king
because i i [ __ ] agree with you hold
on one second i got some donations i'm
backed up on let me play them here give
me a sec uh let's see
[Music]
funding for the puppet army hi i'm
getting funding for the puppet army jj
you're [ __ ] troopers
i just received new orders let's face it
this is a
good grim end awaiting her that's what
mike testa wrote
uh chiba chiba for five dollars says
come on come on give it to me give it to
me
give it to me
found one dead in his van after noticing
a funny smell every time he drove by
walmart has become the third world it
tries one more one more this is the last
one
thank you so much hello my greatest ally
royce you are an upstanding tax paying
patriot
merch is the shale we need permanently
permanent anarcho-capitalism thank you
john stossel john stossel listens to the
show what you were saying dustin
i'm saying uh if she keeps sewing
without whining the crap
she needs to move right in with sam in
their [ __ ] van
yep sam sam and mary on a road i would
watch that
who wouldn't watch that sam and mary on
the road
yeah i hope they don't have sex and
break the damn axle on the land
what do you think jj what do you think
about sam and mary solving mysteries
around the country in a van
what do you think about their uh hair
dyed pink nipples rubbing against each
other stop
it no
dustin's with me here that's gross
you're not gonna turn it on me i'm too
quick
it's [ __ ] gross don't do that you
[ __ ] sick [ __ ]
i hate you no please leave the puppet
almost
you leave the goddamn puppet alone god
damn it
we imagine these two have kids running
around this earth
oh my god oh no please don't you imagine
them pre-creating
they have they all have bad hips and
[ __ ] mayo in their hair are you
kidding me
one more thing california's gonna have
to pay for right yeah california will
have to pay for you rocking the
breakfast pepsi
there uh dustin yep yeah that's right
see him punk in it i'm with you
hey how you been dustin by the way if i
forget this dumb bit how you been today
what are you up to today uh nothing much
i
just uh last night my dad's friend came
by
last night we had some pork chops and
nice
and we drunk a couple beers and plus
he brought some um some moonshine
and some apple apple pie
flavor apple pie moonshine crushing a
couple beers
eating some pork chops you're living the
life dustin it was 128 proof
that's the good stuff all right i'm with
you buddy
actually i'm going to be getting like a
jar of it and i'll be sipping on that
oh yeah sipping that moonshine you you
play hey we got a place
we got to play some call of duty with me
and jj what do you play on ps4
yeah i play on ps4 all right that's fine
but we can we could cross platform play
we're gonna talk offline i'm gonna get
your info so we could play together
all right we'll do some zombie killing
also when you uh come to the state above
north carolina to pick your girl up uh
stop in my area i'll get you some more
of them uh
jars that you like oh there you go yeah
[ __ ] hang when you go to virginia
buddy
and by the way just you know the
moonshiners episodes that they film are
are filmed like within 20 30 miles of
where i'm at so
yeah that's great i know tickle yeah
dustin do you do you want people to play
with you what would you do you want to
give out your your ps4 gamer tag
uh it's coming well is camaro
ss z71 camaro ss z71 sick
now is that your activision id too no no
no it's not it my
my ps4 is camaro
ss z72 i meant
my xbox is camaro ssz 71
oh no no no what i mean is active to
play call of duty with people that are
cross-platform you have to get an
activision id so we're going to need
that one
don't worry about it next time you're on
there um
if you want it i'll send it to uh
senator roberts my homeboy
yeah send it to me just just go into it
at the top right of the screen you'll
see it just send a picture of it and
send it to me we'll add you
all right we'll go kill some [ __ ]
zombies am i right
oh yeah and we can pretend like all of
them are
or uh sam yeah we'll do that we'll kill
we'll kill those people dustin i wanna i
gotta hop off here because jj's got to
do his show so i'm going to let you go
but thank you for being on man i really
do appreciate it
man i love you all yeah yeah hands up
hands up
i'm going to let you do it today go
ahead no i i know i don't want to i
don't want a hollow victory
no go ahead i don't want a hollow
victory yeah d-lab.tv slash jj
i wanted the hollow victory and i took
the hollow victory
i was lying about the hollow victory i
actually did want it
and i took advantage of it and i did it
anyway